un comportement qui va t'arriver
l'avez-vous de vivre une expérience hors
de votre portée imaginez un lieu où il
n'y aurait aucune loi aucune règle
aucune conséquence bienvenue chez pas
ici
me paraît utopique où vous pourrez avoir
ou faire tout ce que vous juriez maicon
et ce complexe fournisse 50% des revenus
qui garde cette ville sur les variétés
quand une fille dans mon monde je peux
très bien envoyé en prison n'importe qui
peut séjourner et commettre tous les
crimes ont calé le rêve
vous savez quoi c'est exactement le
contraire qui se produit les gens
offrent des expériences
sauf qu'ensuite ils en veulent toujours
plus
on y tue pas de vraies personnes tu sais
il ressemble et agissent comme des
humains et permet à nos clients de vivre
l'expérience la plus réaliste possible
c'est du pur divertissement ils émettent
une pulsation qui efface les 24
dernières heures de leur mémoire
monsieur les images me reviennent à
l'esprit pas envoyer une équipe va très
vite remettre en bon état pas tu
t'apprêtes à vivre l'enfer
si la nouvelle se répand que notifie
ciel qui a tué les gens courent les rues
et c'est ce qui arriva entendu
ce complexe n'est que la pointe de
l'iceberg mais pas sur le débat spock on
ferme cet endroit la seule personne qui
veut mettre la main sur ses trios tôt tu
vas continuer en france et dans le
terrier du lapin blanc tu es tu sais il
ya plusieurs façon de chasser à la
parade
voilà la même apparence mémoire parce
que j'étais dessinée à son image est en
danger à cause de moi je dois t d
il ya peut-être une façon pour
copenhague où device une fois pour
toutes un jeu tu comptes fasse une mise
à jour pas mal pour un roe brad
vous croyez que les choses ont changé
rien que vous puissiez faire pour l'en
empêcher
je vous demande quel est le mal c'est un
peu de bien